we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P I've been talking
about in the midst of the Chick-fil-A
Fiasco I've never been to a Chick-fil-A
and I said maybe I'll go to one this
weekend when I'm going to be out in Long
Island they have a bunch of
Chick-fil-A's there but when I looked at
like their breaded chicken sandwich the
ingredients looked so toxic that maybe
I'd go with like the grilled and a bunch
of people wrote to me and here's a
voicemail saying David don't get don't
get that that's not the right item to
get
I hear you're thinking of going to
Chick-fil-A yeah and you say you want to
get the grilled chicken David no like
restaurants have certain items on their
menu just for people like you like when
you go to a steakhouse they have salads
but the salads aren't any good it's just
for people that are in the group that
don't that don't eat meat or don't want
to stake but the salad's no good just
like you go to a seafood restaurant like
they have meatballs on the menu but you
don't get meatballs at a seafood place
which is on the menu for people that
don't like seafood true because why even
a seafood place so don't go to
Chick-fil-A and get the grilled chicken
Dave you have to get the Chick-fil-A
original uh chicken sandwich I recommend
no pickles because they're these cheap
little they're they're not well other
people said definitely get the pickles a
real quality pickle so
um you can get no pickles add lettuce
and tomato
um and you gotta get the waffle fries
David because waffle fries have more
surface area
um so really all right I get the point
listen I I Pro I tend to agree like I
get the the sandwich Chick-fil-A is
known for is the breaded chicken
sandwich the thing about it is you look
at I just was cruising the website you
look at the ingredients it's like uh rib
meat injected with water
I I don't even really know what part of
the chicken the rib meat is I had to
look it up and it's like some connective
tissue between something and it I it's
not even a part of the chicken I was
familiar with it sounds really toxic it
really does but I do agree that
if I'm gonna do the Chick-fil-A thing I
should probably just get the classic the
classic sandwich so I don't know if
it'll end up happening I will report
back if it does and we'll kind of go
from there on today's bonus show we will
talk about Ken Paxton the Attorney
General of Texas being impeached we will
talk about how in Minnesota cannabis
users can't own firearms despite a new
law and we will talk about the two-year
prison sentence given to the woman who
threatened Nancy Pelosi with hanging
during the Trump riots all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com it will be a fantastic
day for everyone otherwise we'll see you
back here tomorrow on the Friday show